when I say my team I mean the colic
leaving this the blog that I do like the
content I put out I also come from the
wine business and so some of the stuff
we do to drive results habits that world
so I just wanted to sit in because if he
doesn't I'm not capable of like follow
up Alex the same he's does business
development on my town so something
Victoria Secret always sounds like a
million dollar bra that's right very hot
sexy yep so I didn't see anything there
and then I'll get something very hot and
sexy and we're talking boxers theory
yeah something cool so nothing and I
said I want to figure out if there's a
business here because it seems like
there's a demand so I you know I met
Jason and Annabeth
here she apologized doors but she was
she was a former editor a fashion editor
at Vogue and she was at Seventeen
magazine she had the whole fashion
photography background got it Jason did
private label he's a designer he could
make anything if you need something now
they'll probably go back and get it free
so he's their mentor wise so I not like
a pumpkin pie okay collectively as a
unit okay okay
anyway so I researched it I researched
Calvin Klein basically had you know some
97% of the market share for men's
underwear at the time when I was looking
at like what the market was revenues
unbelievable this is a premium boxer in
category you you know you would put it
as my Calvin had such a big percentage
like metier metier but they were really
dominating the entire market so we
talked about things like I believe you
know I wear a lot of loriana and all of
that so we looked at the Loro Piana
cashmere which Jason was able to source
we we retain the commissioned artists
like Richard Phillips to toe rock people
who do 12 so we have 12 you would like
this one small I don't want to find it
but famous athletes in compromising
positions like Derek Jeter be found
caught in bed yep we have Larry Bird who
was on the cover of Sports Illustrated
and by accident looks like - yep
cheerleaders giving him a blow job yep
which they retracted at one point
Muhammad Ali
so Muhammad Ali we did a special because
of his passing but we have the number
eight buried all around so anyway so we
came up with some really cool things I
don't if you
cashmere we also came up with
compression compression shorts that
Equinox voted number one in the country
for the best compression short you know
while you're working out
yep this is the cool so this is picked
up by Gorsuch which is the number one
store and Aspen and Vail there there's
catalog there's a three million right
it's like a baby special anyway Gorsuch
has a three million reader subscription
for their catalog and all that and such
as in Vail what's the price points high
of course well that's what you went out
to do right yeah so we do a lot with the
eight so this is eight hundred we sell
out every time he can't get it we sell
out all the time at eight hundred people
selling these are 78-68 yeah yep we have
this selfie we have the selfie so if you
take a selfie of yourself in it which we
both people well put it on Instagram
Jeff this comes this way and then flips
over so we have kind of very cute and
clever ideas that our designers came up
with we were up our Basel we were
featured at Art Basel and how how long
has the company been around well a year
enough that we've launched new in
concept and you know together took about
18 months to get the market yeah try
that week we had a launch party at the
church street boxing gym with Travis
Scott on them on the ropes standing up
with us you know is a waist waistband so
we've had some really great great press
GQ magazine Vanity Fair and the business
is selling mainly through retail or
direct to consumer website got it so
what percent of your businesses
unless we don't okay yeah so so it's a
weed and if you're if you're high
because your eyes get a certain retina
whatever he told me you see this that we
pops out well if you're high I wouldn't
know
so they say what what percentage of the
business is directed solar versus
direct-to-consumer of course keep the
margin and how are you driving sales to
compress mainly met so far yep we also
featured in many background so they're
they're featured in movies you know
Baldwin DeNiro
in various movies that are they've come
out and premiered so we did we try to
use various product placement projects
and all of that SEO or SEM SEM and any
Facebook but you're not running Facebook
ads got it and and Instagram or
influencers on its rap but neither one
you don't have an internal asset that
understands digital marketing so you
have to know what our best sellers are
we know
the forward you know what's next and you
know I think we've created a vocabulary
for the Brin sort of a culture of what
we do and how we do think it's not
typical of other brands out there right
now so it's what we can present you need
to have an internal resource for digital
marketing if you're gonna be a direct
consumer brand okay first and foremost
like from like a religion over tactics
that's the first religious thing you
have to do otherwise you're at the mercy
of an SEO firm that is probably doing
Facebook terribly wrong even though the
Facebook SEO is easier to show black and
white and is a twenty-year practice so
anybody can do SEO kind of thing versus
most people can't do Facebook but all
the action is on Facebook and and and
Instagram especially for a visual brand
your visual brand Google Google find
somebody searches boxers or
what-have-you and you can win that game
but it's blue letters it like if you
really understood if you really gave a
[ __ ] enough to really understand what's
happening in Google it's completely the
antithesis of what you're building it's
completely commoditize branding sure
whereas Instagram and Facebook or visual
like your blue letters are the same as
blue letters of like private label hot
you know the least expensive boxers in
the world look exactly like you on
Google Google do letters so you're you
not only is it is there ways to do it
better it's also a detriment to your
positioning and all the effort you're
putting into it to most of like and then
think about 80% of your business is done
online and I have to assume an
unbelievable proportions of the traffic
coming in outside of like a good article
in a you know a search term is going to
be the SEM so that's super important to
me and so I think the follow-up to this
is going to be how much do you want to
pay for somebody and then I'll try to
help get you the best possible person
for the lowest possible you know kind of
thing so I'll give that some time I
think that's the that's the big big big
takeaway so what do you guys want to
happen that what like obviously want to
build a biggest brand
world and you view that as happening
through your direct-to-consumer world
are you guys thinking long-term of
having your own retail experiences like
how are you thinking about distribution
would that be in New York the first
store I'm asking a pretty specific
reason because I want to give you the
strategy against the creative social
like if the answer is yes and because
you're not going to spend a million
dollars a year on Facebook ads or maybe
you are but I'm making some assumptions
I want to localize this strategy against
the place that you're most likely going
to open the store okay I think so okay
what else going into I mean obviously we
had you know I had just only met your
husband so he I don't know how much
context that was there anything that you
guys had coming in mentally into this
meeting questions or thoughts or
anything you wanted me to talk about you
know whether we should yeah yeah you
know do we stay and do more of the same
cuz it's good do we start expanding and
you know it's weird because we have a
lot of women who are wearing wearing
this two men right if you go to our
website it's men but we have a lot of
women I don't know how much ribbon you
do guys have no worries but it's no it's
not that crazy not crazy
the reason I asked that question off of
your rant is my intuition is it's a
common thing this is one man's point of
view you'll get some different points of
view on this I think people go too wide
too early
I mean look you're you guys are a team
of quality and taste you haven't even
begun to go down the path of sales and
conversion right right
everybody has their strengths and
weaknesses right I think you guys are a
game of quality and taste and the
reality is that makes you an artist and
what makes you a business is sales and
conversion and the cool thing is you've
outsourced that now who's the agency you
guys went with did you guys I don't know
that is but do you are you got a
relationship with them or you guys met
with a bunch of people or how did you
come about got it yeah I mean that's to
me how much are you spending with them
if you're truly spending 30,000 a month
I have some great news you can do some
real damage like you can well of course
I mean look by the way you can do damage
with $1 it's not gonna be the it's not
me the greatest damage in the world
here's the good part you're already
spending enough money to see meaningful
results and I don't know if you are not
do you I mean do you have any feel of
what you're doing in revenue per month
through the EECOM channel that's okay
that's okay but but to that point are
you guys I mean I still think that that
brings some interesting intrigue to the
conversation around art and science like
if if somebody's got to be grounded in
that [ __ ] right and it can't be your
accountant somebody's got to be running
the business and by the way I've run the
business I run this business it's a
hundred million dollar business there I
don't know [ __ ] about numbers I have
people do it but I'm grounded in them
because you have to have them for
strategy right you know what I mean like
to me
finally you should focus on what you do
best
I'm less worried about how much you're
making I'm worried about what your money
is being spent on to make what you want
to happen when your spending three
hundred sixty thousand dollars a year in
advertising I can have all of Manhattan
giving a [ __ ] and you don't have that so
correct so what I think you have is nine
is two thousand four digital marketers
who are making a margin on you and and
if you know I know could possibly in the
future but you gotta justify every month
so dancers I stopped that got it and I'm
looking I am looking for a way you like
you're saying what makes sense dollar
wise to get this going you know I think
it's Instagram I think it's snapchat I
think it's Facebook
I think it's YouTube I think it's where
the consumers attention like my
intuition is my intuition is it ends up
being both okay but think about it it's
like me being it's like me paying for
art it's not what I do and if I'm the
decision-maker I need you to be my
partner to be like is he right I want
you you guys at least on paper I want
you to have somebody to know if we're
the best if Rick's the best if Sally's
the best you can't it doesn't say you
guys don't have the background for
judging sure you have taste you know if
this is a good if you asked me to know
what the [ __ ] this should cost I mean
dad you know that in your sleep I want
you to have that asset on your team so
when all the characters like me come
around
you know they know what the hell they're
talking so yes I think that's important
and and I think the other thing that's
running through my mind is you know a
lot of people that work for me wanna
work in small companies and they come
here for training and so I might be able
to help with somebody who's young which
will cost you less but trick but skill
above their age and can do it all
creative and you know cos you a crazy
question have you thought about building
your brand I think that is the biggest
wild card so I think you should do all
that but if you asked me how it becomes
big it's because you became big and and
in the same way what he's doing right
now like there's a new way to become big
I actually think I'm aware
I understand and by the way by the way
this is not an age thing what we're
inventing but just so you know no no no
no and they can all attest to this all
the 20 year olds in the world don't
understand what I'm talking about I'm
talking about the modern day human
production company around a person
there's no 20 year old running around
this they understand how to take a
selfie they understand that snapchat is
important they don't understand the
science that the 15 people sitting out
here that all work on just my brand
understand I do and so today and they'll
go on to you they're like crush with me
or like it will be known because once
somebody figures something out the world
will know but I sure do basically what I
know right now is we're sitting on a
capability that is what reality TV was
in 2000 and once in a while you come
across a person who actually can play
like it still takes Talent like my early
intuition on you is that you have that
thing and you need to debate it
talents I'm not the talent they but
they're the talent and I feel like they
have the product and they have the
quality and then I feel like it's my job
and my wish to to get it out there I
think I think the way I kind of think
about it is if tomorrow Bravo came to
you guys and said do you want to do a
show about your journey and building
this company you would seriously
consider it and we I mean I don't know
you like how you got white or like [ __ ]
that or that's great but you would
seriously consider it for the exposure
of what I do your business and I think
you would do really well in that show
and I think when I see that they need to
like you need to get grounded in what
vlogging is and all this stuff
it could blogging video blogging okay
it's basically a reality TV show like
I'm not joking when I tell you that if
you asked me push comes to shove to be
historically correct on the thing that
made your business big it would be a
human being following you around the
camera every day yeah we're I'm so
interested in it that we've been
spending the last six months
in about three months we're gonna launch
something called Vayner Talent so I've
been talking like Tyra Banks are like
Curtis Martin football player like a
bunch of different people we have
figured out something for me in the last
six months and I've been on social media
and producing content for a decade but
in the last six months we've really last
year we've really figured it out and now
we're trying to figure out if we can
scale it as a as a it just it's funny to
me that that $20,000 a month charging
somebody for something like this would
bring them a lot more business than what
we do best in the world here on Facebook
and Instagram creative and ads it's cool
it's just how the world works so
something you should sleep on I don't
necessarily need you to as a client but
I can show you how it's done you could
hire it internally but it's obviously a
very personal decision like I'm not
joking I mean a reality show like there
is a man or a woman for that matter that
follows you around and it's you yelling
at Leon it's you shopping it's your
meetings it's you having business me
like it's a show and it airs on Facebook
and you
and I believe it would be the biggest
gateway drug to the growth of your
business but you know and but I think
it's a very easy thing to understand
today if you think about Skinnygirl or
if you think about the Kardashian
phenomenon or the fact that dj khaled is
gonna make people the psychological
punchline yeah rubbernecking it's just a
deep inherent human thing it's called
Yenta syndrome got it it's just it's who
we are it's what people are we're
generally interested in people and the
people know they just want to see the
truth got it
that's why what I'm doing is gonna beat
reality TV because reality TV is just
more of the truth of TV but this is way
more of truth the way out distribution
Facebook and YouTube but then think
about what you do what what people don't
know is so now we take $1,000 and we run
the ads we've run so we run you put
nobody knows who the [ __ ] you are here's
episode one of you no one gives a [ __ ]
but Facebook is the best ad product in
the world
so you post it and then we run a
thousand dollars worth of ads against
the employees of Saks Fifth Avenue
Barney's and Nordstrom's so now if I'm
Sally on the Upper West Side and I work
at Nordstrom's when I'm going through my
facebook feed and seeing my friend's
daughter I'm gonna see episode one of
your shell in my feet ninety four out of
a hundred me like I don't give a [ __ ]
but six are gonna watch it day after day
after day depending on how interesting
and clever and how well it's edited and
how well the ads are targeted you built
they run the gamut he D rocks laughing
because we're airing on Monday an hour
and thirty minute of it but normally
ours runs tech mine runs ten to twenty
five we've got our first beta outside of
me a graffiti artist and motivational
speaker again how much
longer those been 20 minutes yes you
would have for you we would have to have
you yes that's a very good point in the
first move I clearly got it got it
I'm sorry so so so so the punchline is
we would I know you are but but I love
being respectful you we have a strategy
session at first we there's a very good
debate to either it being your page or
the company's page and we would talk
that you'll see in the deck we're making
for people it's the first thing it says
is we're reverse engineering you give me
the most famous person in the world and
be an introvert means we're not working
together right you may be so famous that
you don't want to do it any like like
you've got to be the right person people
don't have to I have no time like time
is a factor I don't show my children
just a decision my wife and I made I
wish I did because it'd be even more
viral I mean huh you know but but that's
something important to us so all we do
right which is huge family kills like
I'm leaving millions of views on the
table especially with my two characters
everybody plays their own thing right um
as you can imagine I do a lot of
business so a lot of the stuff never
makes it because I'm having I'm firing
somebody I'm talking about somebody
salary would negotiate things that TV
shows that are six months away that
nobody can know about so you live life
you know
yes yeah I need some people ask for him
not to sometimes I feel uncomfortable in
the scenario no it's my business life
it's not just here it's in Finland and
it's Orlando yeah yeah that's right it's
a business show it's a life it's my
entrepreneurial life I reference my
family but I just have a funny feeling
you've got some upside in that and it's
something you should two minutes and you
should sleep on it
intuition was right I think so like it's
just so it's so black like I almost feel
like I see life in a different lens like
when I see it I just know and the truth
is unlike learning the craft of how much
does this cost learning the craft of
what these 800 people do what's so great
about it and you're gonna know this you
just do you it's it's the easiest thing
to do in life
so someone think about some of the thing
about by the way but like by the way it
could be only about you and you're a
side character it could be the show
about the whole business and there could
be four kept like it could be cheers
they could be you know it that's right
okay
it can be anything you want it to be
because here's what's better than
signing a deal with Bravo you're in
control of the final at it yeah that's
where it gets real good now the thing is
I would recommend that if you try to
micromanage too much and not listen to
what we know which is you have to show
vulnerability you have to show real
humanity like you have to show the [ __ ]
you don't want to show otherwise nobody
gives a [ __ ] because you're back to
television got it something to me so I
think those are those are two things you
should be sleeping on a you know a real
digital strategy for 2017 not for 2006
uh and just and be a real conversation
amongst yourselves of like is this the
right model and this is a model that
literally exists only with people that
film themselves vloggers on YouTube that
have transcended I'm not good at that so
I made my own version of it which is
this but it's real we know that and then
they're all I do them all
nope because no because most people use
social media to blast out you have to
create for it so content that works on
snapchat snapchat is me first person
always
whereas YouTube and Facebook is the
distribution of the show got it
Instagram is me but I use that for
motivational quotes mainly you know so
dip dip dip dip all strategy like the
thing that people don't understand is
this is the world this is the actual
world of communication and there's real
scale and everybody thinks it's just
like oh it's social media it's
exponentially harder than print like if
your lovely partner was here I would
absolutely make her feel inferior to the
skills she deployed against print
because it was easier it's just easier
my you know it's a matter fault but just
the truth like this is very complex
nuanced and detailed which is why
everybody thinks its first so everybody
doesn't think it's a big deal and then
when they spend on it and they aren't
successful they don't think it works it
works you didn't know what to do with it
you know much money I would make playing
a piano you know what I mean but Billy
Joel makes [ __ ] billions you have to
know what the [ __ ] you're doing
so alright good yes I mean email let me
know if there's anything I can help with
yeah we don't pleasure take care thanks
for hanging you guys but you can you
could really out like go and cliche and
I don't know you but I'm just giving you
like like you could win the housewives
sex in a city thing in a real way I'm
telling you right now you could you have
to think about it I don't I don't want
to I don't know here's what I can
promise you I can promise you you can
come in here and sit with me and Lindsay
and I'll walk you through what Vayner
talent is I I'm still work um you know
you know what makes a great salesperson
somebody that really believes in your
[ __ ]
I know we've got it I really believe in
it I'm scared of two things one that's
why I'm beta testing with this one
person I really want to triple check
because I want everybody talking about
me behind my back the back
because I make five times twenty
thousand dollars a month to give a
speech I'll do that it's not about the
money I want to build something
eventually that could be worth billions
because that's what production companies
are and - I need to know you better
because the because I have a lot of
empathy for what it takes what they'll
tell you is for all my intensity
I let the creators do their thing I
don't control the message and I've been
in this for 10 years understanding this
world here I just threw a whole new
thing for you to think about it you
never thought about it yeah now you mean
right now you're gonna think about it
and even if you say yes 100% I have so
much empathy for you wanting to be very
in control of the final output and in
that is a lack of speed which is the ROI
of the whole thing so I need you to be
in the know business not the yes
business what I mean by that is you sit
down you watch for 23 minutes and you're
like no that one thing I can't like my
sister will kill me not not right not
right right not not not oh I don't like
that angle right you're just gonna lose
yeah most of all yourself
yeah because because by the way getting
into a place where people are stopping
you cut like I'm getting stopped 1015
times a day in the street it's changing
my life you know with my daughter and
fans are yelling out and she's like
Daddy you like you know like so you know
and by the way people like you and I we
want it we want it and yeah you're the
you're in a different place yeah you're
too much yeah here no much that's
correct
in a different place but but I will tell
you this you will sell [ __ ] I build a
one hundred million dollar business on
my brand you will sell [ __ ] you'll get
an e yep you know you you will get it
you will get an email from QVC saying do
you want to work with us you will get an
email from for an unbelievable shop in
Naples Florida that has four locations
as says we love you we watch every day
we want your product when you come to
the store you'll get an email from
HarperCollins often you $100,000 to
write a book it will happen that [ __ ]
30,000 a month deployed against this for
one year
$2,000 we'll pay you back millions this
is the New World Court take care yeah
stay well bye-bye you really think this
is right for her huh I'm going off your
vibe now by the way some things you can
and some things I can you know what I
mean I was rich I was with Joe Biden two
days ago we don't feel that like you you
know but you push for as much as you can
yeah okay all right take care bye-bye
take care